so if I already know I'm gonna say nice
things about this episode am I now
locked into that and I can't alter that
timeline before the flood wrapping up
this little two-part story and yeah I
like this one quite a bit that's your
spoiler free review let's get right into
it there's actually a lot about this one
that works in a way that didn't
necessarily work in the last and I like
the first half of this story I liked
under the lake but some of the things
that I mentioned like the supporting
cast not quite clicking they were by and
large better for me here I think it's
because they kind of split them off
there's the couple of characters who go
with the doctor to the Past is the one
who stayed with Carr on the base and
sort of separating them so we could get
them more isolated and get more
concentrated interactions with
characters that they actually you know
had stronger chemistry with helped the
overall vibe of the supporting cast
rather than just ramble about everything
that was good because I'd be listing
most of the aspects of the episode I
really kind of want to focus on
something that I was just the feel of
the thing this thing had kind of a
gothic horror vibe that that a lot of
the really good classic era doctor who
like the Hinchcliffe era or something
like horror of Fang rock had this kind
of gothic horror vibe to it that
actually maybe genuinely nervous and
scared from members of the supporting
cast cuz usually supporting cast members
in Doctor Who modern era either you know
they're gonna be fine or you don't care
enough about them that if they do die it
gives any impact but seriously when that
sort of captain woman who's deaf she's
walking down that hallway and there's
the ghost behind her dragging this axe
and it's so loud but she can't hear it
that was genuinely tense and because the
whole thing had that gothic vibe I had
no security and going oh they're gonna
be fine no it's like no they really
might not be it's the sort of thing that
like I said we used to get in the
classic era more often it's a vibe we
don't usually get in modern Doctor Who
too much and I really like it I like the
revealed villain of the Fisher King I
like his design I like his voice I'm
sure there's some who will complain
about you know the voice doesn't really
match up with end with the
sheíll movements of the creature but I
don't care and again that creature kind
of has a classic era Doctor Who viable
because usually the better design Doctor
Who monsters from the classic era tended
to not have a normal mouth or you know
they had marked off masks or things that
they didn't move you know things
characters like Omega or su tech so the
Fisher King also kind of has that
old-school but this really is an
old-school Doctor Who type episode and I
really do like that and I like how it
kind of reestablishes the the firm yet
at the same time loose relationship that
the doctor has with cause and effect
when he gets locked into things versus
what he can actually change and I do
feel the show has actually been pretty
consistent on it if you get down to the
nuts and bolts of when things turn out
that now he can't change it or now he
can but I'd like when those things get
addressed I think the solution was also
really clever again the sort of oh the
ghosts turned out to be a huh grab that
could have been a cheap that could have
felt really cheap and unarmed but
because we'd already set up the hologram
previously with what they used with
Clara in the previous episode it works
and it pays off well pretty much across
the board
I really just love this thing I mean if
I'm gonna be nitpicky there were two
things that I didn't care for one's
really nitpicky if we have the alien I
forget what the call but for the ones
from the planet that's always being
invaded and I like that race I liked
when we saw one before in the god
complex and I like kind of the whole
theory behind them but the the one in
the god complex was just you know he was
a coward on a very fundamental level
that's like the fundamental makeup of
his entire society the idea that
cowardice is kind of well yeah that's
the best course of action and I liked
that but one in this one he kind of had
a masochistic streak going like he
wanted to be dominated and conquered and
I didn't like that as much it was a
violet in love but that's nitpicky
though the one thing and I know why it
happens it's a writing plot convenience
and it's a contrivance but I still don't
like it because logistically there's no
reason that we should not have seen the
ghost of O'Donnell earlier than when we
did because if she
been dead the whole time like the ghost
of Prentiss the the the alien mortuary
funeral director guy we should have been
seeing her for as long as we've been
seeing him cuz she's been a dead and
been a ghost for just as long but we
don't see her until this episode after
we know she's already been dead for plot
convenience and I might not have noticed
it except the doctor himself points out
the fact that they hadn't seen her ghost
and that kind of drew my attention to it
again I understand why it's there
because it's a reveal and it's a
contrivance to get you to that reveal
but the show should not have pointed
that out to me because I might have not
noticed otherwise but really these are
just kind of nuts and bolts and they're
side things I mean the heart of this
thing the ghostly vibe become a gothic
horror feel to it I I love it and
there's a whole lot of little touches
that I think are great to like like the
the hologram and the TARDIS that goes
through the emergency procedure whatever
it is is wearing the older-style outfit
that the doctor was wearing last series
as opposed to what he's wearing now or
when the doctors sort of facetiming with
Clara and she's using the phone and he's
in the TARDIS talking on the monitor
that he has to turn the monitor this way
or that way depending if Clara's holding
her phone like this or like this just
little touches like that and just give
me more to love in this episode I just I
thought this was fantastic so if you're
watching this I'm assuming you saw the
episode two what were your thoughts on
it whatever they were drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it until next time this council is
adjourned